estelle bonjour alors où en sont les
livraisons de ces fameux masque une
dizaine de millions de masques c'est la
cargaison qui a accueilli hier aux
alentours de 14 heures l'aéroport de
paris-vatry situé dans la vendent à 150
km à l'est de la capitale
sur ces 10 millions de masques sept ont
été directement commandé par l'état
français
le reste provient de dons faits par des
entreprises chinoises à la france c'est
en tout cas ce qu'a indiqué pialet ngan
le préfet de la marne ses sept aéroports
de paris vatry qui a été choisie pour
recevoir la majorité des commandes de
masques et d'appareils respiratoires
faite par la france à la chine selon la
direction de l'aéroport la prochaine
livraison aura lieu demain
sachez que pour le mois d'avril 16 vols
de ce type sont déjà programmées alors
ces commandes elles vont transiter par
le biais an du fameux pont aérien entre
les deux pays
en tout l'état français a commandé 600
millions de masques l empire du milieu
pour faire face à la pénurie qui touche
l'hexagone je vous rappelle que chaque
semaine les personnels soignants en
france son besoin de 40 millions de
masques pour faire face à l'épidémie de
kovy 19 la france and an produites
actuellement que 8 millions par semaine
c'est donc dans ce contexte extel que
des associations saisir le conseil
d'état pour demander au nom du droit à
la dignité humaine des réquisitions
nécessaire face à la pénurie de matériel
et de médicaments
oui exactement tout ce sont six
organisations qui se sont réunis dans je
cite une coalition inédite alors parmi
elles on peut citer act up paris le
collectif un père hôpitaux ou encore le
collectif inter urgence ces
organisations elles ont saisi le conseil
d'état
hier malgré aller mesure d'annoncer en
notamment par le premier ministre
edouard philippe dans son allocution du
28 mars
ces organisations estiment que cela
n'est pas suffisant pour faire face à
l'épidémie de kobe 19
elle s'inquiète du manque de matériel
c'est à dire de masques de blues ou
encore de test ainsi que du monde de
médicaments dont souffrent les
établissements hospitaliers
ces six organisations réclament donc des
mesures fortes et en particulier la
réquisition du sinn pour faire produire
le matériel manquant de son côté le
conseil d'état 1 s'ils jugent cette
requête recevable de vraies filles
c'est une audience dans les 48 heures
suivant la présentation de ces
observations par le représentant du
gouvernement
merci beaucoup et c'est el farj pour
toutes ces précisions